maybe you saw our letters in foreign
ladies and gentlemen if i may have your
attention please
i'm radex sikorsky a resident fellow
here at the american enterprise
institute
and we've gathered together here to uh
discuss the world bank one of the key
institutions of the modern world
and the occasion for our panel is the
publication of this excellent book
the world's banker uh by sebastian
sebastian malabi
uh who's been a um correspondent and
uh columnist for both the economist
and the washington post including his
excellent column on
on the pension accounts in the paper
today
hundreds of millions perhaps billions of
people still live in poverty today
so the issues of development are key
are very important um although i have to
say that the figure of um
persist of people surviving on
less than two dollars a day which
may sound shocking but i recall not so
long ago
uh when i lived in communist poland
myself
the market value of my parents salaries
was about uh 20 per month
and all right i mean we overthrew
communism and there was a reason for it
because uh we didn't like the way we
lived but it wasn't grinding poverty
exactly
uh so i i hope um we'll look
realistically at those figures
um but the one thing i would like to say
is that this is an extremely well
written book we'll
discuss the academic merits uh
of it as well but uh i would like to
recommend it to anybody who would like
to
know more about the world bank and it's
um
larger-than-life um president mr
wolferson
without further ado i'd like to ask
sebastian
to give us uh the speech the
introduction
hello welcome sorry um
please give us a half hour version of
your book sebastian
sure thank you reddick it's great to be
here at the american enterprise
institute i thought i'd just briefly
tell you how i came to write the book
uh tell you a little bit what's in it
and then pick on a few of the themes
thank you um so i thought i'd tell you
quickly what's
how i came to write the book pick on
some of the main themes and then pick on
also a few of the kind of policy debates
coming out of it
i've been interested in developing
countries for a long time maybe going
back 20 years or so to
backpacking trips around latin america
long trips to south asia
and this interest was very much cemented
when i became the economist magazine's
africa correspondent based in zimbabwe
traveling around the continent from
zimbabwe and you know i went all around
i was deported from sudan which i think
is now a badge of honor given the
genocide in darfur i was outside nelson
mandela's jail
in 1990 when he came out and i was 25
years old at the time and of course my
career has been downhill ever since
because nothing could quite match the
excitement of that
moment but i didn't regard development
although it was my interest as being
natural
a natural subject for a book at least
not a book that would
break out into a wider audience until
after
the 9 11 attacks when it became clear to
me that this interest and development
was becoming more of an issue that would
you know that appealed now
to the broader foreign policy community
because of the perceived connection
between
state failure and and so on uh
on the one hand and security on the
other uh
the obvious point being that al-qaeda
had been based not only in afghanistan
but before that in sudan
and so the connection between it wasn't
just strong states that
threatened our security it was actually
primarily weak ones
and so one could see approaching a sort
of repetition
of the third cycle since the second
world
war of this of the interest
in development being sparked by security
concerns
the first of these cycles came right at
the end of the second world war
um in 1944 with the creation of the
world bank and the imf at the bretton
woods meeting
and that was clearly something which was
sparked by the experience of the 1930s
where inflation and mass unemployment
had led to
fascism desperation had led to desperate
isms
and it was to sort of avoid a repetition
of that
nexus between economic breakdown on the
one hand
and war on the other that the world bank
of the imf was set up to try to underpin
the economic
reconstruction of western europe
and the second phase of this connection
between security and development
i think came when the cold war hotted up
uh particularly with the cuban
revolution in 1959
and in the year following that the world
bank acquired its ida
soft loan window that was a big
expansion in its ability to go out and
throw money around and uh
of course john f kennedy in the early
60s was talking about the alliance for
progress
and development again achieved a kind of
a new salience because
of the perception that if you didn't
help poor countries
they would fall into the communist
column and it's i think indicative that
the classic economics textbook at the
time of development economics
was will resto's stages of economic
growth
and the subtitle was a non-communist
manifesto
so that was sort of phase two in this
connection between security and
development
and phase three i think is happening now
uh and we've seen this
in the numbers of overseas development
assistance
which have gone up i think roughly a
third uh globally
uh since 2001 in response to uh the 911
attacks
um so we so we had this consensus and
that was the first thing that
made me feel that a book about
development might break out of this sort
of small technical
uh interest group and the second thing
that made me think i had a subject that
might work was
realizing that in the character of jim
wilkinson i had us a larger-than-life
figure
who would make any stories sizzle
wolfenstein is not
whatever you think of him a boring guy
he made north of 100 million dollars on
wall street
he represented his country in the
olympics he placed the cello on the
stage of
uh carnegie hall with his friends yo-yo
mar and so on
he has a rolodex that goes from alan
greenspan to the dalai lama
to harrison ford um and when i was
wondering whether i should write this
book or not
uh i asked the world bank if i could get
some access to him spend some time with
him
and i was told sure absolutely you just
need to go to canterbury in england
uh uh stop me slightly strange i'm at
the washington post in washington he's
at the world bank in washington we're a
few blocks from each other
but anyway i flew to london took the
train to canterbury and in the shadow of
the big cathedral i
found this little seminar room where you
had
jim wilson on the top table next to the
archbishop of canterbury in his purple
shirt
next to him sri swami agnivesh a hindu
mystic with a big nice orange turban
and and next to sri swamiyage there was
bono with his black shades and black
shirt and black stubble
and i thought anybody who could put a
coalition together spanning the
archbishop of canterbury
a hindu mystic and a rockstar
was somebody who would make a book move
along and indeed he does
he's there as sort of the central
character so you have this
larger-than-life figure on the one hand
jim wilson
uh and the larger-than-life issues of
aids and
malnutrition and poverty state failure
and these this sort of romantic match
between the big person
and the big issues is what i think uh
moves the book along and wolfensohn um
just to give you a sort of quick
uh summary i mean he's sort of extreme
in both directions he's extremely good
in that he's brilliant and charming and
dedicated to his job
he is quite bad also in some ways
because he loses his temper he's very
thin skinned he's vain
and so you've got both of this going on
at once and
this sort of dr jekyll mr hyde
switch is one of the animating forces of
the book and
when i gave the manuscript to one point
to a friend to read part of it
uh he he read this thing and he said you
couldn't work out whether this was
actually
sort of a noble figure or a manic crazy
one was
it ben kingsley or danny devito and the
answer is that he said of both
so the combination of of the post-9 11
atmosphere and the
character of wilkinson made me want to
do the book and the book takes you
through the big
sort of set-piece arguments and
development in the last
10 years or so the reconstruction of
bosnia the asian financial crisis the
battle against aids the story of how
uganda
cut its poverty by 40 in the 1990s
and some of the more recent arguments
between the bank and uh the bush
treasury
uh are all in there and it's supposed to
put you in the kind of the cockpit of
globalization and fly you around so you
get a good aerial view
the evolution of our understanding of of
how to make development happen
how do you take a sliver of the rich
world's wealth and turn it into progress
against
poverty and the story here really of of
development since the second world war
is one of
repeated failure and disappointment uh
leading to
uh coming up with a new theory as to how
you can try and make it work better
and so in the 50s you had an emphasis on
physical capital um the idea being that
there was basically a financing gap in
poor countries
they had plenty of labor so if you gave
them more capital then growth would take
off
uh when that didn't work terribly well
in the 60s there was a shift from
physical
capital to to human capital uh and so
there the idea was okay well maybe the
workers weren't so productive after all
but if we give them health
and education they will be productive
and so we know with the physical capital
and the human capital
will make it work that didn't really
solve it so in the 70s you had
experiments with um you know so the
green revolution
and agricultural research you had
population control initiatives
then moving into the 80s you had to
focus on the macroeconomics because
there was a perception that
however many projects you did if the
environment economically around them
consisted of hyperinflation and budget
deficits and no price signals and
bad state-run industries you know you
could forget it and so there was a focus
on the macro economy and that experiment
was run
through the 80s and the early 90s and
when that also
produced less results than had been
hoped for the idea was
it's not just the economics around your
projects it's kind of the politics
around your economics you need good
institutions you need competent
bureaucrats you need to think about
corruption and transparency how
legitimate your policymakers are because
they can pronounce
the best policies in the world but if
they don't have the political legitimacy
domestically
they can't implement them um so that was
uh
i think the consensus that emerged from
the mid 90s to the late 90s and
i think holds to some extent today and
it's the emergence of this consensus
which i tell
the story i tell through country
examples like bolivia uganda and so on
which were quite influential in the
emergence of this consensus
where does that consensus leave you in
sort of you know policy prescriptions
for the
donor community well i think it it leads
you to humility basically
because first of all we know that we've
tried a series of experiments and we
didn't always have the right answers
and secondly uh if the answer is that we
need to think about institutions and how
efficient they are
we don't have a good sort of uh
toolkit for implanting good institutions
in other countries
it's one thing to say look you need
price signals you need to fix this
budget deficit we can look at your
numbers we want to close that gap that's
a fairly simple thing to analyze
but how do you make a sort of health
ministry
work efficiently and that's very hard to
do
and therefore the consensus is a you
should be humble and b
you probably need to select the
countries that are doing the right thing
if a country is on the right track
and the world bank comes along and gives
it extra money and extra technical
advice and extra policy ideas
you can probably accelerate the progress
but if it's not on the right track
because it doesn't have the right
institutions and it's not doing the
right thing
you probably ought not to lend it much
money you should engage you should have
a dialogue you should try and identify
promising reformers
within that government but you shouldn't
kid yourself that you can take this
country going in the wrong direction and
move it into the right direction
even in cases where in the 1980s there
was a relatively simple
understanding of what the policy had to
be it was these macroeconomic
things you had to fix even in those
cases there are celebrated cases like
pakistan
which over a quarter of a century or so
signed sort of 20 something
agreements with the world bank of the
imf all of which committed pakistan to
cutting its budget deficit but the
budget deficit
did not shrink throughout the period and
so one has to be a bit humble about the
potential for conditionality
to achieve results even on questions
where you sort of know what the result
is that you want
and when it comes to building
institutions uh it's all that much
harder and so i think the world bank as
i as i described it in the book
came to this consensus about some
humility and some selectivity in which
countries you should support
if you look at where the soft loan
credits from the world bank
went in the early 1990s you find no
correlation whatsoever
between the quality of a country's
policies and and
sort of the competence of its policy
makers on the one hand
and how much aid it got on the other
there was no correlation
but in the second half of the 90s when
there was a perception that
you've got to get behind the good
performers the correlation becomes quite
significant and so you see that the
world bank is selecting the better
performers
and this is a consensus which of course
now has been taken up also by the us
government
with the creation of the millennium
challenge account which operates on the
same principle
of selecting um 16 or so countries
which seem to be doing the right thing
and supporting those countries
with extra money so the selectivity idea
i think begins
with the world bank and fans out into
the u.s government and one of the
stories i tell in my book is sort of the
ironic tale of how
um paul o'neill the u.s treasury
secretary coming in with bush in 2001
spends a long time beating up the world
bank picking aggressive fights with the
world bank
saying the world bank has no idea how to
do development but then the following
year in 2002 when the bush
administration announces its own big new
development initiative
it takes the principles pretty much
directly from the bank selectivity
comes from the bank it's developed by
the bank and not only is the principal
developed by the bank
but how you kind of define which
countries you want to select
how do you choose the good performers
the indices the sort of measures of good
performance used
by the u.s government are taken
primarily from the world bank research
department
so you have this sort of ironic story of
you know the us government on the one
hand
beating out this institution for being
incompetent and lazy
and then basically borrowing all its
ideas when it does its own initiative
um and i think that's a cautionary tale
about how we sometimes view
international
organizations um so that's that's one
thing and i think we could debate a bit
further whether this consensus on
selectivity of countries
is going to last i think it ought to
last but fear it will not last
and the reason for that is that you've
got a situation where the foreign policy
community as i said is throwing money
at the development institutions because
they want to
fix fail states because they perceive a
security threat
but the development institutions are
taking all this money and saying you
know what
we're going to give it to the good
performers and so there's a big mismatch
between the suppliers of this extra
development finance and the users of the
development finance and the development
institutions who are using it for
something
which is not really what they were given
the money for so when i gave a book talk
once to a group that included
brent scowcroft the former national
security adviser you know he sort of
said to me afterwards so you're saying
that um
you're going to give all this money to
the countries that don't need it and
from the sort of foreign policy
establishment's point of view this does
not seem like a good
uh proposition so my suspicion is that
either
the providers of the finance in the kind
of foreign policy
establishment are going to get wise to
this and cut off the extra flows
uh some of which we're perhaps already
beginning to see or
the development institutions are going
to come up with a theory which pleases
their
their bosses their patrons and explain
why in fact you can use
development money in copious quantities
in countries
where uh you know a couple of years
before they said you couldn't use it
i want to talk a bit also now at the end
about sort of the world bank's futurist
institution
i think um some outside observers of the
world bank
uh start with basically two premises you
know one premise is that
uh the world bank is uh basically
malign that uh people at the world bank
don't necessarily
want to try and fix poverty and the
other assumption is that on the other
hand
the world bank is so powerful rich and
established it's got such a nice
headquarters in washington
um that it'll be there forever it's
never going to
uh weaken or fade and we can kind of
take its longevity for granted
i have the opposite views on both counts
i think people go to work at the world
bank
because they do actually want to do
something about poverty
and if they'd wanted to take their phds
to mckinsey or goldman sachs
they could have paid an awful being paid
an awful lot more money uh
and so the fact that they're at the
world bank tells you that they they do
care about these issues
but on the other hand i'm worried that
we can't take for granted the longevity
of these
institutions this institution that in
fact is very weak
and it could be on a gradually declining
path and i think that for
basically two reasons the first is that
there's a structural problem about
managing
a big international organization like
the world bank
wilson came in in 1995 and his tenure is
kind of a case study in
can you apply private sector management
thinking uh to a public sector body like
the world bank
and make it more efficient and he came
in you know not only himself
a banker an investment banker who had
worked with the private sector and
believed in private sector models
but also uh he came in of course in this
period in the mid late 1990s when
the reputational bubble of of the
private sector of the u.s corporate
model
was at its height and people's belief in
the ability to
of this of the ideas from the private
sector to transform the new police
department or whatever
was at an absolute high and so you know
bratton was doing this in the
new york police department and al gore
was trying to reinvent government
borrowing
management consulting ideas uh in the
u.s federal government and wolfensohn
was doing this at the world bank
and essentially the story is that you
can't achieve all that much by importing
these smart
private sector ideas because the reasons
for the world bank sluggishness
come partly or to a large degree from
outside the world bank they're imposed
on the world bank from outside
partly by shareholders who are
constantly convening meetings of the g7
in the summer and saying
you know the priority this year is hiv
aids and then they reconvene the next
year and say
actually the priority is universal
primary education and they come back the
next year and say
you know what it's failed states and
they do this repeatedly they change the
mandate
and then they say actually you're not
focused what's wrong with you you're not
focused and so
this sort of externally driven lack of
focus is endemic
in a big public sector institution and
makes it weak
and the other thing is for reasons that
i suspect professor meltzer is going to
elaborate on
the financial model is is is very is
very troubling i mean
i'm not sure that the bank will stay in
middle-income countries
uh i think it's got probably a declining
role there
professor meltzer think that's that's
good i think it's bad
uh but i we think we agree perhaps on on
the future where it's which way it's
going
and if the bank's role in middle-income
countries uh suffers attrition
the profits that the world bank makes on
lending commercially to those countries
like brazil and so forth
are going to dry up and that's going to
threaten the financial model on which
the bank is founded
and so i think for these managerial
reasons and for financial reasons
we cannot take for granted that this
institution will be around
and that it's uh that its ability to to
contribute
will be there forever and one of the
reasons i wrote the book
is in the hope of sort of waking people
up to that and making people value
what this institution can do and perhaps
rally to it a little bit
it seems to me if we lost the world bank
first of all we would lose a creator of
public goods the world bank is the
foremost
sort of researcher and practitioner of
development
around the world and it's kind of a
clearinghouse for experiences
so that you take the experience of
brazil and doing
you know hiv treatment and you apply it
to other developing country settings you
expect the experience of china in doing
successful infrastructure projects and
you take that to other developing
uh country settings you can
cross-fertilize ideas around the
developing
you're kind of like a mckinsey again
sort of for development
and i'm not sure that market signals by
themselves are going to produce a
mckinsey
for development unless you have one in
the shape of the world bank so i think
we would lose that
if we saw the world bank decline
and secondly i think that this tendency
for uh g7 leaders
to enunciate goals like universal
education and
sighting aids and so forth is partly
sort of hubristic
and unfortunate and exaggerated but also
i mean there is a kind of kernel of need
there that you know there are
transnational development threats that
do
affect our interests in the rich world
and which are morally compelling in
their own right
and we want to be able to try and do
something about them and if we lose the
best tool we have
for addressing those issues i suspect
that we will regret it
thank you thank you sebastian
and i think best tool that we have is
is precisely uh the question
at issue some people of course question
whether
the world bank is a bank at all um as
you uh hinted and as you elaborate
in the book the bank is a controversial
institution
there are those who think that it's a
socialistic
welfare institution and then there are
those who think that it's an agent of
global capitalism that
ultimately driven by the us government
and the need of
the needs of global corporations rather
than the needy people in the developing
world
so who better to address these issues
than
professor alan meltzer visiting scholar
at aei and nancy bertzel president of
the center for global development
whose very distinguished buyers are
in your materials professor meltzer
thank you it's a great pleasure to
review sebastian maliby's book
it's a very well written and enjoyable
book to read
and i urge everyone who is here and
those who are
watching to to read it it's
as a writer myself i can say it's a lot
better than reading or writing about the
federal reserve
there are three main topics that he
talked about and alluded to in his talk
first is jim wolfensohn the person
second
a character of great interest
who really threads his way through the
book and ties it together and makes it
more interesting than it would otherwise
be as sebastian said
then there's the world bank as an
institution and then there's the
relation between the two
wolfensohn as leader and president of
the bank what did he want to do
where did he succeed where did he fail
and why
sebastian describes jim wolfensohn
accurately i believe
he's charming he has the most fantastic
rolodex probably of anyone in the world
he's determined
arrogant strong-willed talented
intelligent
but petulant vain and likely to blow up
at the first sign of criticism
determined to believe that his ideas are
right and others are wrong
eager to improve the world especially
the lot of the poor
no less eager to let the world know
about his accomplishments
i would add he's unfocused
unable to motivate a large group to
be directed toward any goal
and not very capable of writing a large
organization
despite what sebastian said he really
never had much experience
running a large organization his private
sector experience
was in mergers and acquisitions back in
the 60s and 70s
a period in which what was important was
the rolodex
the charm and the ability to get deals
done
but he didn't run a large organization
and that was true when he started
wolfensohn company
so running an organization with 10 to 15
000 people
was new to him and he wasn't very good
at it as the book
pardon me establishes rather well
what did he do he depended on his
contacts
his charm and his rolodex
only once does sebastian describe him
as thinking about how to make the bank
succeed better
characteristically he does it by going
out to his country home
he sits there all alone there's no other
input
there's no real discussion with senior
aides or development officials or
experts
at the bank who know a great deal about
development
the bank is rich in these resources
wolfensohn as
malibi describes him and i think
accurately ignores them all
the job of a ceo especially the ceo of a
large con
company is to ask and try to answer
three tough questions
where are we where are we going and how
do we get there from here
as near as i can tell that's the only
time the wolfenstein ever began to ask
those questions
and he didn't do a very good job instead
he gave he was given to grandiose
visions of development
like the comprehensive development plan
or the new development strategy
suggesting that he was more interested
in the public relations of what he was
doing
that he was in the substance of what was
going to be accomplished
as many have pointed out in reviewing
malabi's book if everything is important
then nothing is particularly important
it provides
these frameworks provided no direction
and they largely were ignored
or given lip service sebastian accepts
this criticism
but it's interest when he quotes jessica
einhorn
but his his dedestation for paul o'neill
causes him to dismiss it when o'neill
says almost exactly the same things
the bank
the bank is a dysfunctional organization
the last four presidents
reorganized the bank that tells you a
lot about the fact
that it isn't a very successful
institution jim wilkinson was not the
first to reorganize the bank
and he almost certainly won't be the
last to reorganize the bank
but most of the organizations have added
layers of bureaucracy between the
president
and the operating officials i think
one recent person who departed from the
bank and has written about the bank
extensively
said that when he arrived at the bank he
was
three levels below the president when he
left the bank he was 15 levels below the
president
all right all that bureaucracy was built
on top
two as one as far as one can see very
little effect
what does the bank do it puts a premium
on making loans
it lacks the idea that there have to be
incentives for development
the word and sentence doesn't appear as
far as i know in malibi's book
although the idea of incentives is
occasionally present
the whopping hands report in 1992 which
was an internal bank document
my commission's report in the year 2000
made exactly the same criticism
the bank pays its people internally for
making loans
and that's what they do they make loans
they don't
really care much i mean individually of
course they care
but the bank as an institution doesn't
care much whether the programs succeed
and it doesn't have a very good system
for finding out whether the programs
succeed
what it does is monitor the programs
mostly
at the time that the last tranche of the
grant or the loan is made
it doesn't come back three to five years
later and ask
did they actually build the school and
their children going to the school
did they inoculate the children against
measles and how many of them actually
were inoculated against measles
that question was is not asked when i
asked that question in an open forum at
the treasury department
of jim wilkinson when he appeared as a
witness before the commission he said
yes that's very important
we need to do it he had already been
president for six years
so we asked him well why haven't you
done it he said well it's a very
important thing and we really need to do
it
i agree it's a very important thing and
they really need to do it but so far
it hasn't been done
here is what malibi says
the claim that the bank may know made no
effort to measure its performance
was just as easily demolished the bank
made many such efforts it maintained a
whole department to evaluate loans after
completion
it had set up a new unit to check
progress quality in real time
and some of the best work on measuring
aid effectiveness came from the bank's
researchers
the last sentence is correct the others
are not the bank made very little effort
to monitor the programs after they were
completed to find out
our children going to the school to the
schools and so
what my commission said was let's do
solve the problem that malibi talked
about
how do we make sure that in countries
where there's a dictator where there's
corruption
where there's malfeasance
misappropriation of funds
how do we make sure that people in those
countries actually get some assistance
we may not be able to make the the make
the country grow
but we can improve the lot of the
poorest people in those countries
how do we do that we give monitored
grants
we say to the private sector you know
inoculate these children against measles
we'll pay for them after we inspect and
make sure that they have been
inoculated bring water to the villages
we'll pay you when we see that the water
is brought to the village
and that was the program which we talked
to paul o'neill about
which president bush brought to the
world bank and which became u.s policy
it was a policy to say let's try to do
something
even in those places where the
governments are corrupt
and unwilling to act let's try to do
that unless the government actually
objects
to the program we're going to have an
effective program of monitored grants
it's interesting to see how much malabi
knocks those programs and yet the bank
has accepted it
finally accepted the idea they changed
the wording from
uh what we called it which was uh
performance-based grants they adopted
output-based aid
but it's exactly the same program it's a
program which pays for performance
and that's what what what it was that
paul o'neill
was saying to to wolfenstein during all
those years
the record is not very promising for the
bank
after 40 billion dollars of loans and
grants to the 10 largest recipients of
world bank aid
they have a negligible 0.2 percent
average increase in per capita income
over the last 30 years
at that rate it takes 360 years
to go from one dollar per capita to two
dollars per capita
and it may be that my friend radek is
happy to live or is at least willing to
see people live on two dollars a day
but that isn't the goal of the world
bank or it isn't and presumably it isn't
the right goal for the world bank
the 700 million people in 42 countries
living on a dollar per day have gone
backwards since 1980 that is they have
lower
per capita income now than they did then
that isn't a very
promising record so the question is
why is the bank so unsuccessful in the
poorest countries of the world
there are two reasons wolfinson imposed
a matrix form of organization
basically the operating people have two
masters
the country people the people who are
responsible for the
what happens in the country and the
subject matter people and this produces
endless problems of conflict
between the two groups that's one reason
but the major reason
in terms of its internal organization is
the lack of incentives there are no
incentives
or few incentives for the for the
success of the programs in the country
payment and promotion and reward go
for making loans whether the loans
accomplish anything
or don't now there are some successes
malibu cites bosnia
but the evidence is that the imf was
perhaps the most responsible there
why has the imf gone in for for
introducing
essentially its own type of poverty
program
no one at the imf will admit this but
they will admit it
privately that is they believe that when
they have a program
in a country which requires the country
to adopt
some kind of macroeconomic stringency
that country must then
will then have problems in its
distribution of income
they don't believe that they can count
on the bank to help solve those problems
so they establish their own poverty
development program
to do what the bank doesn't do very well
what is needed at the bank is focus
the north africa and middle east
division
had the guts to say
to wolfensohn when he asked them why are
things so bad at the bank
they came back with a response which
said there are
the principal problem in this
organization is you
because you're unfocused and because
you lack direction and because you shift
from one thing to the other
without any rhyme or reason and because
you don't change the budget when you do
that so that we're
given simply a larger number of things
that we're supposed to accomplish
with no metric to decide which ones are
the most important
it's a poorly run organization and
wolfensohn is at least in part
responsible for that
here is maliby on page 253 of his book
discussing the bank's publication called
assessing aid
he writes it was quote a devastating
multi-country study of the failure of
donor conditionality
that showed that aid given to countries
that don't voluntarily pursue
good policies is ineffective took the
bank a long time to figure that out
but that in fact is the case that's
exactly what
my commission and paul o'neill said and
and malibu
and that malibu criticizes and it's what
malibu said here
but not in his book he proposed
we proposed make the reforms
then get the assistance without the
reforms
no assistance that would give some
incentive to the countries
they may not be able we may not be able
to stop them from stealing all
stealing the money but we can stop them
from stealing all of the money
wolfensohn deserves great credit for
raising the issue of corruption
yet that was five six years ago
what has happened at the bank that
limits corruption
what has wolfensen done to reduce
corruption other than to talk about it
has he ever thought of the idea about
putting some incentives into the system
and saying
if you don't get rid of most of your
corruption
you won't get any additional aid and
only those countries which establish the
right kinds of conditions
those which are likely to work those
that were pointed out in assessing aid
those are the countries which we'll have
which will have our assistance
sebastian tells us some good stories
especially about wolfensohn and the ngos
but he often fails to draw what i think
are the right conclusion
about some of these incidents he draws
the right conclusion about the
the about the ngos namely that for many
of them
as he says there was no way in which
wolfensohn could satisfy them
and that his efforts to do so uh
turned out not to be very successful my
own story about that was that in in in
studying the bank
and going to to to uh talk to people at
the bank i met
uh i met with joe stiglitz along as well
as wolfensohn
joe stiglitz who was at that time the
advisor to wolfinson and the chief
economist
told me that the thing that they had to
do was to have a little parliament
they had to have the ngos come in and
decide which were the right programs and
which were the wrong programs
and uh that and and that was the way in
which the bank was headed
at the time and of course that meant
that
almost nothing uh effectively was done
there was success in uganda the lesson
is
and i think that's the important lesson
which is repeated in many places
and which sebastian is willing to accept
here although he certainly doesn't
emphasize it in his book
that if there is a local leader who has
an incentive
to improve what is going on he will
bring about improvement
and the example he gives is trumasimi
and mussovany
in in uganda and here is what mussolini
said in a recent
statement
that help comes from the bank comes
through their policy advisory role
those institutions play in these
economies in their mobilization of
resources for the development of basic
infrastructure including roads railways
power plants hospitals schools
water and sanitation facilities to
tackle poverty therefore
the imf and the world bank should in
addition to poverty
policy guidance and resource
mobilization take on another role
that of urging the developed economies
to open up their markets for exports
from the least developed poor countries
a role which the bank has not played but
should play
other examples which could be put aside
put alongside uganda
where some local individual had a
very important role in making the
reforms that were necessary to to get
development
of peru in the early fujimori
administration
i went on submissions at that to peru at
that time
and it was pretty clear that uh that the
government of peru at least parts of the
government of peru
were determined to make the reforms that
would be would that would be valuable
the lesson of all this is that helps
work where a local leader marshals
reforms
so the lesson of that ought to be lend
to those countries
that put the reforms in place don't lend
to the others especially the ones that
are corrupt
insist not on a comprehensive plan but
an actual legislated reforms
implemented that was what i believe was
the criticism that paul o'neill made of
the bank
and which led eventually to the
millennium challenge account
of the administration pay for
performance
sebastian criticizes the idea of grants
and place of loans
i want to make clear that we're talking
about monitored grants
the loans that we're replacing were 70
to 75 percent grants
so when the grant these are loans which
have 40 years duration at one or two
percent interest with 10-year grace
periods
so if you do what the present value of
those loans are they're about 70 percent
grants
what the bank does when the loans come
do is it rolls or rolls them over and
extends the term
so that they don't get paid what we
suggested was to stop all that
foolishness
to end the the idea of having
loans instead of grants and to give them
grants that is to give them grants
a 70 grand is the same as a as a loan
with a 70 grand feature so if we say to
the country on average the very poorest
countries
have to put up 10 of the value of the
grant the the rich the better countries
might put up 90 percent
let's say we have an average of 70
percent of the value of the grant
is paid is paid by the bank is given by
the bank
and the 30 percent it can't be any
different than a loan with a 70 percent
grant value and if you if uh and it's
simply
the the statement that uh this would
bankrupt the bank or take away its money
is false uh my colleague who worked on
these things with me adam lyric
has worked this point this point out
he's taken it to the people
who used to be the cfo the person who
used to be the cfo at the bank
and the bank accepted the idea that the
loans would replace the grants
and i have a paper here which summarizes
all of those which i'll be glad to
give to sebastian to read
so in summary this is a fine book about
wolfensohn
it's less successful about the bank and
and especially about the interaction for
the two
it recognizes that wolfensohn has wasted
his time platicating
the ngos it fails to recognize the role
of
incentives the word hardly ever appears
in the book
how can the bank incentivize local
reformers
without that developing lending fails
sebastian never asks why did the bank
subsidize loans to china
instead of allocating more on effective
programs in the poorest countries
china is able to borrow 60 billion or
more in the local markets
the bank lends it at most a few hundred
million or a billion dollars a year
what in what reason is there for for
china to borrow
on subsidized terms when there are so
many other countries
that are much more in need of that
amount of money
it isn't that the bank makes money on
these loans the bank claims
that it only makes a slight
a slight addition over the cost which
pays for the administration of the loan
instead he criticizes o'neill who raised
these issues such as
why is the bank not more effective he
claims that uh
that my commission was out to destroy
the bank instead
we have we have proposed we propose
things which the bank as i said has now
accepted
grants instead of loans the millennium
challenge account
and he ignores work showing that the
grants do not cost more
sebastian overlooks that the commission
was bipartisan
it had a vote of eight to three in favor
of the grant's proposal
with a range of people going from ed
fullner of the heritage foundation
to jeff sacks of harvard and now
colombia in the same majority
followed by the volcagourious study
group
that that nancy was where nancy was the
executive director
and called for the same idea graduate
the middle-income countries
release more resources for the poorer
countries
sebastian can tell us if he thinks it's
wrong to graduate middle-income
countries
to concentrate more on the more aid on
the poor and the poorest
in effective programs that have a chance
of working
there's much more to be said and perhaps
we'll get to it in the question period
regarding one more statement regarding
paul o'neill
sebastian portrays him as a know-nothing
gadfly
a bit of research would have informed
them about o'neill's commitment
to development after he left the
treasury he continued to work on
supplying water to the villages in ghana
through private resources as i said
everyone should read the book if only to
find out how an intelligent
determined committed strong-willed
individual
individual could fail so badly to reform
the bank
and improve the lot of the poorest
countries
thank you very much and let's now hear
it from the perspective of the ngo
community nancy bertson
oh that's a peculiar introduction
i'm not sure that i represent the ngo
community
i prefer to think of the center for
global development
which i had as a think tank that's
actively engaged with
the public but let me start by saying i
i hope this book is on the top
of the reading list of the next
president of the world bank
it's wonderful to have a book that is
not a rant
neither from the left nor the right
about the world bank
the book is nuanced it's balanced
it's smack in the awkward middle
where complexity and moderation
usually make for very boring reading but
it's not
boring reading now alan makes it sound
like the solutions to the problems
that the world bank faces are easy ones
sebastian in the book recognizes that
development is a complex business
and that it's a risky business and that
there will be
successes and failures my view
is that the book only pretends to be
about jim wolfinson
in some ways it even only pretends to be
about the world bank
i think as sebastian suggested in the
way he opened his remarks today what he
really has done
is write a great book that brings alive
the story of development and especially
about development policy
with all its successes and failures
particularly in the 1990s
which was a critical decade when so many
developing countries were adjusting
or not to the changing reality of uh
increasingly global economy
sebastian's starting point as he said
today in his remarks is that the
development community
is facing now a crisis of confidence
there's a loss of faith in the old
recipes
for how it is that the rich countries
can go about helping
the poor countries that loss of faith
comes from the recognition that progress
against poverty has been the greatest
in countries like china and india
which actually decided not to follow
the economic formulae of the world bank
and the imf
and mostly ignored or at best tolerated
the bank's interest in lending to them
and progress has been leased
in what are still the poorest countries
because of lack of progress
many of them in africa where
in fact along with the world bank other
donors the bilateral donors
now are financing as much as 50 percent
of government
spending and as much as 75 percent
of all new public investments
so rich country money and advice are no
no longer seem particularly useful
the old recipes as sebastian said of
financing capital investments financing
human capital investments
insisting on market reforms sometimes
without much result
in many countries targeting the poor
with lots of spending on health and
education all of those old recipes
don't seem to have helped in some of the
world's poorest countries
and the new idea that what matters is
institutions is is a little bit
difficult and embarrassing because we
don't really know how to define
institutions and as a development
community
we really don't have a lot of good ideas
about how you sustain or create
or sustain institutions at the
government level
that will support effective market
economies
worst of all in part because of the good
research from the world bank
there's a recognition that institutions
have to be home grown
and that means again that it's hard to
know
what to do from the outside
well the way sebastian illuminates and
brings alive
this complexity and the challenge that
it represents
is by telling stories in fact his book
is really not about a lot of what he
said today
it doesn't propose what should be done
it doesn't come up with an agenda for
reform
it doesn't come up with easy solutions
it illuminates the challenge and leaves
to the reader
to wonder what next let me say a little
bit about
the failures and the successes that
sebastian discusses
a list of failures the aids problem
he illustrates how the bank came to that
challenge late and with a kind of
lackluster program
and in fact i think the aids pandemic
is one of the few examples where because
the bank came to it so late
it has not been able to seize leadership
on the policy issue
and it hasn't been able to bring out
even the best economists in the bank
haven't been able to bring out the big
question
of the most cost effective way to deal
with the pandemic
instead we're kind of overwhelmed
frankly by activist
push for or for big spending
independent of evaluating as alan would
say
what's really going on and what's
working another failure is bolivia
where sebastian tells a great story
about an enterprising
bank manager whose ideas were undone
by what sounds like a very small-minded
board that
didn't want to give up even a little bit
of its
its rights and its turf on monitoring
bank lending indonesia uh
i think sebastian is is actually quite
revealing in the way he tells the story
of how difficult it is
in a big institution to change
the direction how how it took too long
for the problem of corruption to be
dealt with
in indonesia and even when jim
wolfensohn pointed it out
how the institutional inertia made it
difficult to
cope in the short in the immediate
aftermath or in the immediate run-up to
the financial crisis
what's good about all this in a way even
in illustrating the failures
is that sebastian does not as alan would
blame overpaid and causated staff
who face the wrong incentives he's very
clear
in fact that this most bank staff as he
said in his remarks
are can-do kind of people who are trying
to bring about
change um and in fact he paints
wonderful portraits
of heroes amongst bank staff and
managers who took a lot of risks
and made things change in fact let me
get to that in a moment
let me say something about
the honesty with which sebastian
places blame for the failures and here
what's well known now about the book is
that he blames the ngos
for imposing environmental and other
standards and safeguards
that have hamstrung the bank as a
bureaucracy
and made it move even more slowly made
it
even more risk-averse than it was
before the rise of the safeguard
movement
he blames very clearly a know-nothing
u.s congress for preventing the bank
from doing what might have been
a perfectly reasonable project in a
province neighboring
tibet he blames the bush administration
in a very interesting story for its
failure
to exploit the bank's policy
wisdom and its potential for financing
reconstruction in iraq and there comes
the comparison to what the bank was able
to do in bosnia
bosnia is one of the successes and again
there's a story
about bank heroes you know who uh
face down the the bullets and so on and
face down in some ways
the customs and procedures that normally
mean that getting a loan through the
board
takes months and months and he tells the
story of success in uganda
uh the the question really that he
doesn't address
is whether there are other successes
that were not due to exceptional
cases of bank staff and managers taking
unusual risks
we don't really get a sense of whether
those stories
about these bank heroes are the
exception
or not he's very clear
on i think a central point that is
that the bank is the brain trust of the
development community
and whether or not individual loans
and financing efforts in developing
countries have worked
there isn't much question that the bank
along with the imf because of its
emphasis on markets and the reality that
markets need to be made to work
as well as the emphasis on the role of
government
but mostly the emphasis on markets that
because of that emphasis
in some very general sense over the 80s
and 90s
the norm changed the standard changed
all over the developing world so that
even today in countries that aren't
growing
in africa at least they're not failing
to grow anymore they don't have negative
growth
because they have better macroeconomic
policy
because they have tried to undo some of
the status policies that were
adding to their problems of corruption
they've done privatization they believe
in markets
let me say a little bit um in the spirit
more of quibbling
than criticizing uh about what i think
sebastian
doesn't get quite right i think the
emphasis
is right on the reality that staff are
committed
but alan meltzer has a point that
there's something about the fundamental
incentive structure inside the bank
that makes it hard for the bank to
get out of countries where things aren't
going well
and and that exit problem is not
really brought out by uh in in the
stories that sebastian tells
there are times in the book where
sebastian
seems to be suggesting that the bank has
a lot of leverage on borrowers there are
quotations like you know the
importance of banks policy push on this
or that issue
and i think that perpetuates confusion
in the larger community about the fact
that the bank
really and the fund have surprisingly
little leverage
uh and that seeming to say that the bank
the bank has leverage
is course is of course inherently
inconsistent
with the idea that sebastian does bring
out and allen referred to
that the you have to have ownership
uh for any changes and for any reforms
at the country level
i think that the emphasis on the problem
of the ngos who as uh sebastian has this
great
language his language is he's really has
a way with words i'm not sure it's in
the book but i've heard him say it you
know the ngos
don't have an off switch they'll just go
on and on no matter what with their
criticisms
i think that although all that is
true it fails to bring out
the fact that the bank was slow
that it created a lot of hassle for
borrowers before the rise
of this pro the creation and rise of
this problem
of the overdoing on
safeguards in the 80s and 90s if you go
back and ask people who
knew the bank in the 70s in the early
80s believe that
believe me they'll they'll make the same
complaints and that's why
there were the same rounds of
reorganization
which by the way are not exactly unique
to
quasi public institutions like the bank
i mean it's not
as though when alan says the bank is
dysfunctional
ask yourself how many you know ibm has
been dysfunctional in its
in its history enron was dysfunctional
so let's not um let's not
assume that it's something about the
public nature of the bank that is
key to its whatever dysfunctionality
there is
on what's what's also not quite right i
would say
in the end that in sebastian's remarks
although
not in the book he exaggerates a little
bit the threat to the bank's um
future that comes from the left
from the ngos uh in his remarks today
i think he got it closer to correct
when he brings out the threat to the
bank's futures that comes
from what i would call crudely the right
and although i i want to resist
um getting into a debate with alan that
i'll never manage to win in public
being too much myself in that awkward
middle um
where sebastian is and he's more
effective i'll leave that debate mostly
to sebastian but let me say
that i think the real threat to the bank
does
come from some confusion on the right
about this issue of grants versus loans
and some conflation of what's going
wrong in rich
in the middle income countries for the
bank and what's going wrong
in the poorest countries for the bank
and let me say it this way
even sebastian is bound to agree
that it would be better to move to
outright grants
for the poorest countries that are
failing to grow
virtually every economist now agrees
with that
this is not because former idle loans
have not been repaid
it is a big exaggeration to say that
former ida countries include mexico
brazil
korea by the way and they include a lot
of countries today that are still poor
bangladesh sri lanka that are paying
back their loans
it is it is only actually a group of
relatively small
with some well sudan ethiopia are big
but it is just
an exaggeration to say that that idol
loans have been a problem
still the fact is that for the poorest
countries many of them in africa
virtually everyone now agrees even the
bank
in some institutional sense recognizes
that grants make more sense
however for the middle income countries
the reality is
that the bank is a brilliant concept
invented by keynes and others its
founders at bretton woods
it's a concept that says let's exploit
the triple-a rating that the rich
countries
command in private markets in order to
raise capital
and lend to middle-income countries at
somewhat lower rates
there will be risks there will be
failures
argentina is one of them but it doesn't
mean
that there aren't great benefits at the
global level
in supporting that kind of transfer of
resources
and it doesn't mean and and i would
assert
that without that function there that is
the vehicle which allows the bank
to have the leverage to do the best
practice across
rich and poor countries to be the brain
trust
for the development community
let me end by saying
that it's important if you haven't read
the book
to realize that the book is mostly these
good
stories in which you are left to judge
what's to be done about development and
what's to be done
about the complex issues
that the world bank grapples with as an
institution day or after day
in sebastian's remarks he's starting to
write
what i hope might be another book which
is what's the reform
agenda for the bank it's an exaggeration
to say by the way that the volcker
gorilla
commission recommended graduation of
middle-income countries
what it recommended is a more nuanced
kind of thing which is differentiate the
borrowing rate
so that the richer amongst the middle
income countries
pay higher costs when they borrow
and that will create an incentive
for the bank bureaucracy to reduce the
hassle
that good performing middle-income
countries pay
and it might generate a little bit more
income to
sustain the kind of programs in the
poorest countries that would make sense
so in the end what i like is that
cutting through all the controversy
about
the bank and about development issues
sebastian ends up an optimist he
believes
in the reality in the in the possibility
that this great development project
can be made to work and he recognizes
that if it's to be made to work we need
an institution at the global level
that has the brain trust we need an
institution at the global level
that helps civilize the magic
of the market just as governments at the
domestic level
civilize what otherwise would be
unfettered markets
by using taxes subsidies regulation
etc in order to ensure more and
a more equal more equal opportunity a
more competitive environment
uh and to ensure that well i'd say put
it that way that we have
a market system that is
more civilized more compassionate
and and more focused on in the end at
the global level
this great challenge of reducing uh
poverty in the world
thank you thank you sebastian i'd like
to give you
five to ten minutes to respond to the
points that uh have been made and i'd
like to add a couple of my own
i i started by saying that we once lived
20 years ago in poland on less than 60
dollars a month we no longer do so
poland has a
per capita income of over five thousand
dollars and growing rapidly
now all that happened without um
with the world bank and the imf really
quite marginal to the process
and the reason was marginal is almost by
definition
once you have reforms you you fix your
own institutions you ch
you pay savers a market rate for their
savings
the internal savings of a country by
definition much
bigger than any amount of aid or loans
that foreigners can bring in
so here's the argument that you don't
actually need an outside institutions if
you pursue the the
right policies my second question is
this
the capital that comes into the bank it
does not come from
the etho it comes from somewhere it came
comes from
taxpayers in the rich countries now
would it wouldn't it have been a a
better way of
financing development if we'd left that
money in the
in the private sector in incentivized
citizens
in rich countries to donate more to
international development
christmas is coming up at this time of
the year i usually give 200
uh to a catholic mission in in india
and a few months later later in the next
year i get a letter from them telling me
what they did with my money isn't this
uh
a fairly efficient way of controlling uh
where the money goes
um and at this at the more intense at
the
at the more uh at the level of higher
spending isn't what
uh bill gates is doing in africa uh
a a more admirable a more efficient way
of pursuing um
development and lastly um
you said in your talk that we need to
identify the winners and then help them
win
well something very important is
happening right now in ukraine
a country with a thousand dollars per
capita income
hopefully the reformers are going to win
uh
the reforms are going to be painful um
to really help them we would need to
scramble a program together and apply it
in three to six months
in your judgment having studied the bank
is the bank capable of doing it
thanks very much relic um well maybe
i'll start with the ukraine question
because um
that does relate to the experience of
bosnia
i think slightly which is another
example of a country which
you know had the dayton peace agreement
and then needed some
kickstart economic activity immediately
for that piece to stick and the
impressive thing about the bank in this
particular episode is that
the bank through the leadership of some
determined people there
was in fact way out in front on bosnia
had
secret meetings in warsaw with
bosnian leaders who escaped through the
tunnel out of the sarajevo
siege during the war and then made it
to warsaw where they met technical teams
in the world bank to discuss what
reconstruction would require
and all this was going on before there
was even a ceasefire then when the
ceasefire came
in late 1995 immediately uh the bank got
a plane uh a c-130 transport to fly a
team in before there was a piece and
when it was just a ceasefire which might
or might not hold
so these people were flying into a war
zone you know the as the planes were
landing
the the pilot was yielding you know run
run run because the snipers around the
airport were in action
and you had to kind of travel around
sarajevo and an armored personnel
carrier and have meetings in basements
and so on
and so that is you know ukraine is there
isn't a war going on at least there's a
lot of
civil tension but the bank in sort of
these special circumstances
where there are green lights from the
board from the shareholders
when nobody is sort of criticizing it
and saying you know your development
isn't effective you haven't measured
this impact that and
it is capable of putting people on a
plane and doing things
fairly quickly um in in some settings
and i think
so bosnia is sort of the optimistic uh
half of of my answer the less optimistic
half
would be to take another analogy which
would be the asian financial crisis
where in fact um the imf was uh much
much much more effective
at uh coming up with fast programs they
didn't always work
but the bank was pretty flat-footed in
that setting so
it sort of depends on you know if if
ukraine
um can get the sort of support from it's
it's partly a political question
if if the board including not only the
united states but also all the europeans
and
japan um are willing to say you know go
do this and we're not going to
you know second guess you on every
single project you put together
then the bank can be very fast and it
requires that sort of bosnia-style
consensus
in a setting like iraq by con by
contrast the bank has not been effective
because the europeans
sort of you know didn't agree with the
us foreign policy on iraq and therefore
were dragging their feet and
throwing up obstacles and so the bank is
only as good as the consensus
in the political community behind it um
on the question about bill gates and
uh you know the um other
ways of transferring money i mean i
agree that you know there's often a role
for
private i mean there is certainly a role
for private donations
for foundations like the gate foundation
which don't have a board
um that are second guessing you bill
gates and his wife are the board
it's their money they can do what they
want so if they decide on tuesday to do
something
they can start activating it on tuesday
afternoon and that's a glorious thing
and if there were more bill gates i
would be delighted
but i think there is a sort of
particular niche that the world bank
feels this is this big
intergovernmental organization which can
go there when things are going right
with the sort of backing of
the international community and go to
the new fledgling bosnian government and
with some degree of you know speaking
for the world
act as the quarterback for a
reconstruction plan or can go to
a developing country and sort of
co-chair the
donors conference and again act as the
quarterback trying to coordinate
uh aid efforts in in a country and i
think that
you know the gates foundation does a bit
of that because it's so big
but the bank's role um has been
um i think to fill the niche of being
big
and governmental and operating into
governmentally and that's not
the answer to development but that's a
component of the answer to development
and
for that the bank is quite useful um
i'm going to just say a a couple of
things about um
nancy's remarks and allen's remarks
i i think that um you know
the big picture to kind of try and keep
hold of here is that
we don't really have a choice i think
about whether we care about development
i mean
um the fact is coming back to the post
911 point
is that we are in this the walls that
seem to divide
the fortunate one-fifth of the world
from the unfortunate four-fifths
are porous and through those walls come
all sorts of threats from aids to
migration
to environmental problems and indeed to
terrorism um
and so i think that we need to start
from the premise that we need to engage
in development and we need no the world
bank is the best tool we have
when it came to setting up the global
fund for aids tb and malaria
one might have thought that the world
health organization would be the lead
agency
but when it came to decide who should be
the manager of this money in this new
global fund everybody agreed
that the donors the rich governments
would never give the money
uh if it was anybody other than the
world bank managing the money
and so the world bank has become sort of
the financial trustee for the global
fund
uh equally when it was a time to you
know talk about universal primary
education
one might have thought that unesco which
after all is supposed to be an
educational organization
would be the lead agency but again
everybody agreed that nobody would
contribute significant money
uh to a global uh primary education
campaign
if unesco was the lead agency so the
world bank became the lead agency
there's a reason why
the world bank gets pulled into all
these diverse challenges because it is
simply the best big development
organization that we have
and so messing around with it uh is
dangerous and
that's i think the premise against which
one has to judge
any comments about uh you know is it bad
is it good should we criticize it more
uh should we criticize it less i think
that criticism is healthy and fine
but when it gets to a point where it
could undermine
the support for the bank um too much
then one should be worried and i think
that alan's comments
you know do sometimes stray from sort of
constructive criticism
to slightly destructive criticism uh and
there are three examples um from his
remarks just now that
i'd like to suggest uh may cross that
line um
you know simply the chronology on the
debate between paul o'neill and the bush
administration which was
reflecting the meltzer commission's
ideas
the chronology tells you quite a lot on
this question
of you know you should back good
countries and be selective
alan read a quote from my book from the
assessing aid study at the world bank
the date of that study is 1998.
the precursor studies that led up to the
1998 volume were being done
so 1996 1997. so this is before the
meltzer commission reports this is
before o'neill is in office
so the idea of selectivity was was was
um present inside the world bank um
before any of the uh bush stroke meltzer
stroke o'neill
critique was really publicized
and the point of this is not just to
score points about who was first no no
no
that's not the point the point is that
the bank
had thought about these challenges but
then was accused publicly and
aggressively and repeatedly
of being so dumb it hadn't thought about
it and that's the problem that's that's
where i get worried where the
where the critique sort of spills over
into saying you haven't even thought
about this stuff
the point of my book as i think nancy
correctly said is to say that the reason
why the bank doesn't sort of seem to get
it right all the time is because the
intrinsic challenge of development
is so difficult that of course it
doesn't get it right all the time
venture capitalists in silicon valley
give money
to ventures that fail that's in the
nature of venture capital and
you know if you think venture capital is
risky what do you think about putting
money into uganda or senegal or burkina
faso of course it's risky of course
you're going to mess up sometimes
so i just think that that sort of the
the jump to say
you know you haven't even thought about
this is sometimes incorrect
um this idea of shifting to output-based
aid well i have a story in my book
uh about bolivia as nancy mentioned
uh where in 1998 1999 bolivia shifted to
a plan of output-based aid
where the world bank was only going to
say okay we'll agree on some targets you
want to have four main development goals
you know you the government tell us what
they are we'll pledge a bunch of money
to you
and we'll come back and measure in two
or three years whether you've reached
the outputs that you've promised to
reach
and if you don't we'll cut you off and
if you do we'll carry on supporting you
that was output-based aid
at least of a sort and it predates uh
paul o'neill's arrival in government
and equally on this question of
incentives well as i said in my talk
uh in the first half of the 1990s there
were no incentives because money flowed
indiscriminately to countries
irrespective of whether their policies
were good bad or medium but in the
second half of the 90s the soft
credits flowed um there was this high
correlation between
having good policies and getting the
money so there were incentives built in
i think the incentives could be
strengthened right in that sense i agree
agree with alan
and i think that the millennium
challenge account is a pure aversion
of building incentives in and to that
extent i think it's better
um but to say that there were no
incentives at the world bank that they
didn't get this point it's just an
exaggeration
and again i worry about this not just in
a kind of point-scoring way
but because i i care that that we that
the criticism spills over
into something that ends up leading us
with the view that look
you know we don't need this institution
it's not terribly good anyway
you know we can do without it so let's
just criticize it all we like
um and so finally when we talk about
something like grants
versus loans um i'm actually i also
didn't get this point across
clearly enough i'm actually all in favor
of grants i think grants make a lot of
sense
my question is if we're going to shift
to grants and at the same time we're
going to say
well you know middle-income countries
should graduate and not borrow from the
bank
what is our model for the financial
structure of this institution 20 years
from now
if you make grants that means you're not
going to be paid back even the 30
okay it's 70 grand already but the 30
percent which is loan in which you are
paid back for
if you lose those lose those repayments
you're going to have a smaller ability
to land down the line
if you pull out of middle-income
countries you do lose this margin
this profit that's made that helps to
cover the administrative costs of the
bank
and again you're going to have a weaker
world bank uh 10 years down the line
it seems to me that you're you're making
the world if you make the world bank a
grants only institution dealing only in
the poorest countries
you're heading the world bank down
towards being a u.n
agency which is responsible which is
which is dependent on the largesse
of the rich countries that donate money
which therefore of course don't don't
name money reliably or as much as they
should
and so you have un institutions which
are which underperform which are
managerially worse than the bank which
are intellectually less good in the bank
and which is why whenever we have a big
challenge whether it's aids or universal
education
we don't go to the un primarily we go to
the world bank given that our revealed
preference is that we like the world
bank we go to it we use it all the time
do we really want to compromise this
instrument
excellent some passion impassioned
arguments and i now
open the discussion to the floor please
uh if you couldn't
introduce yourself and wait for the mic
yes
my name is sarath rajapathiran i'm here
visiting
school scholar the american enterprise
institute and like nancy
i must say in full interest of full
disclosure i also work for the world
bank for a long time
and i enjoy reading sebastian's book for
the stories
and the stories are very interesting
because the stories
about about some of my colleagues who
might admire tremendously
and he got stories right but they're all
about winners
the bank staff that sebastian discusses
all about people who do wonderful things
and some remarkable people who are there
but i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about the institution
as ellen has tried to do this morning
what is the main objective of the
institution what is he supposed to do
has not been clear the reorganizations
four
organizations that i sort of
was in uh as a receiving end
was trying to get the objective function
right
what is supposed to do now we have in
this panel discussion
this whole question has come up again
helping the poor countries
being in the middle income countries so
it's not very still clear it's very
important
to be able to do that and i didn't get
that impression from rebecca
reading sebastian's book that conundrum
the problem has been solved in my mind
two i think the incentives are very
important and as like alan i say
i look for the word incentives and if i
come do
um a word check for the word incentive
versus poverty poverty is
thousands of times mentioned but
mentioning the word poverty this
really doesn't help they are not being
incentives as radek men tried to say
this
morning what are the incentives the bank
supports
the bank is very successful when it has
supported countries
that were having the right incentives if
you look at the people
countries that have succeeded in the
last 50 years
the other countries without that have
really
worked on their incentives uh provided
the incentives to
for open markets and savings
so i would like to see in a book in
which two it talks about the
what is the main purpose of the bank and
where it is going it's a very important
question to uh what are the incentives
that
countries can support and i think that
on middle-income countries i favor
allen's point
that it's sort of a financial fiction to
say
that the bank is a viable financial
institution because it lend to
middle-income countries
keynes and others who fashioned the bank
had the idea of graduating middle-income
country that's in the original
paper written about the bank thanks
sebastian would you like to do this one
sure i mean of course i agree that
uh incentives price signals are
absolutely key to development and
there is some stuff in my book about the
way that the bank
was you know in the 1980s spent most of
its energy trying to get the price
signals right in developing countries
and this was the right thing to do um so
anything we differ on that the question
i i guess
i'm not sure that a a word check of the
frequency of use of the word incentives
is perhaps the best measure of
how much one cares about them but um
you know i so i i guess i would just say
i agree with
with with your point and i would point
out that the world bank historically
has been perhaps one of the leading
agencies in getting those incentives
implanted
in poor countries and in trying to
persuade them to move to market signals
anybody else on this point
i i think it's it's perhaps
misleading sebastian to point to
the 1998 assessing aid i mean i don't
claim any priority for these ideas
but it's wrong to appoint to the 1998
assessing aid
and then say well the bank had that idea
they had that idea
within the bank but your book is about
jim wilkinson
and he didn't take that idea he there's
nowhere that he accepted the idea
let me just describe one conversation
that i had with him
all right we he he had the usual
charming jim wolfensohn
one-on-one kind of approach you know
everything went fine
finally he turned to me somewhere
through the lunch and said
uh now how would you reform the bank
and i said of course i haven't studied
the bank carefully enough to be able to
do that
what i would do is i would have a
performance audit an independent
performance audit
i'd go out and find out which of these
programs work and which of the programs
fail and his answer was
that would destroy the bank right
i think that tells you a lot about jim
wolfinson in the bank
my criticism is not of the bank or of
the need for the bank as a development
agency and as helping the countries
it is to find out why the bank
doesn't succeed better than it does and
i think the answer to that is
it needs to separate out two kinds of
problems
one is institutional reform how do we
get countries to reform their
institutions
anybody who thinks that's easy or who
think that i think that that's easy
or simply a technical problem is grossly
mistaken i think that's the hardest
problem about development
but the other problem is how do we help
those countries where we don't get
reform
but where we may be able to improve the
lot of the poorest people
and that's the grants pro that's what
the grants program is intended to do
and then there's a third problem where
the bank does much less than would be
desirable
and that is how does it supply global
public goods how does it make sure
that the countries for example that if
it's working in burkina faso
that the pollution problem which arises
in burkina faso
also affects the neighboring countries
around it and why doesn't the bank use
its resources
to bring those countries together into a
regional compact to do that the bank has
been
very slow to do that and that's a very
important thing that it can do
on health care on pollution on various
other things the bank just has been slow
to do that
right so you don't want too much on this
hello my name is bruce rich i'm the
director of the international program in
environmental defense and i actually
talked with sebastian a couple of hours
in the preparation for his book and i
do appear in a minor vignette somewhere
in the middle of the book though
uh well let me say reinforce some of the
positive things that you've said about
the book it's a
for all of us all of us who care about
development issues it's important to
make these issues lively engaging
exciting and he certainly does a good
job with that with jim wolfinson
there is a bit of a kitty kelly-esque
approach of uh
reciting anecdotes which are hard to
verify or not but i think in this
case i would use the kitty kelly eska
approach as a compliment for its
engagingness
however when you get to the the thesis
of the book and particularly
the conclusions and there are some
recommendations
i think then the kitty kelly-esque
approach doesn't work quite as well
and um let me say i would uh uh
sebastian's uh
general introduction was my i could
agree with 98
of it what he said here today
unfortunately that's not quite the book
that he
he wrote and the main thesis is that jim
woofinson
he's unfocused he's trying to do
everything at once please everybody
this is just compounded problems and
that the bank's performance as we all
agree
has been consistently consistently
disappointing
partly because of the challenges of
development but i would agree partly
because of what
alan meltzer and the others have pointed
out
for a long time because of the uh some
deficiencies in the
internal incentive system the pressure
to lend and when you get to the
uh sort of the bottom line of
sebastian's book he blames the
messengers for the problem he
says towards the end he says well you
know the problem is wolfinson has
listened too much to these ngos who are
nitpicking pointing out problems and
projects
uh you've got the conservatives who come
up with their standard critiques and
and they're just badgering the bank and
and the banks should really just
ignore a lot of this and uh uh and go
and and uh satisfy the clients of
borrowing governments get the money out
quicker and so on
but that's part of the problem and i
think but what is most serious and i
would invite everyone in this room to
examine the uh
some of this quite closely is that he he
uh
misrepresents there are very serious
material misrepresentations almost
caricatures in some cases
of some of the uh the critics i mean i
was rather astounded to hear alan
meltzer almost uh
admonished as if he were an ngo without
an off switch that uh
watch out your criticism may be getting
a bit
negative rather than construct it and i
i think that's a
kind of indicative of the of the problem
here
uh paul neal is caricatured as an
ignoramus and i think that's a
frankly a bit over the top uh the
meltzer commission report which i read
very closely which
i even though i come from the opposite
end of the political spectrum i agree
with the
uh some of the essential findings and
you know and i even wrote an
op-ed piece on this a couple of years
ago uh
it really does identify the central
problem the lack of incentives
to to promote quality the the pressure
to lend
it's very directed at how you can help
the poorest people in the poorest
countries
and it also
uh was a bipartisan commission it was
not just as you said
characterized it or characterized in
your book uh the latest conservative
critique saying that markets have made
most of the bank absolute absolutely
when you get to the ngos
you use two or three examples in your
book as an example of how the ngos
get things wrong somehow they managed to
convince the finance ministries of all
the western industrialized countries
to swallow things and and stop otherwise
good projects that would have helped the
poor and i'll just take the example
that you mentioned at the beginning of
your book and which you mentioned again
in your foreign policy example uh our
article
the bujagali dam in uganda
and you point that out you have your
opening chapters prisoners of lilliput
and you point out well
you went to uganda you there was this
big dam
which would have provided energy help
poor people and you had the
the berkeley mafia the international
rivers network which
was in touch with uh some almost
exiguous tiny ngos in uganda that which
were
raising some environmental criticisms
and this is an example of how good
projects don't go ahead
well the real story in bujigali which
you admitted but you evan publicly when
at
the session for the center for global
development
was that the main issue was economic and
corruption the ngos were pointing out
that the power purchase agreement that
was being proposed was being kept secret
that it was economically
uh exorbitant simultaneously
four governments the united kingdom
norway uganda
and the united states justice department
launched corruption
investigations into this project late 99
aes because of energy trading
speculation that resulted
in huge losses almost went bankrupt as
95 percent of their stock value
disappeared and that was the reason that
concurrence of events for
donor governments for shareholding
governments conducting
uh corruption investigations
aes almost going bankrupt that's why yes
that's why aes pulled out of the project
that you don't mention any of that
but that's one of the key examples you
cite in your book
uh for uh how ngos are stopping good
projects that would otherwise help the
poor i think you acknowledged this you
said the iron was right on five or six
of eight points
and so on but that's not what you wrote
in your book well thank you
mr malibu defend yourself okay i'll try
and defend myself
i mean you know one of the interesting
things here is that um you know
bruce rich uh who rather modestly didn't
tell the story about himself which
appears in the book which is quite funny
that
um he'd written a very good uh very well
cited book
uh called costing the earth about the
world bank which came out i think
morgan to the earth i'm sorry um which i
think came out in 1994
one year before wilson uh became
president of the world bank and um
uh so uh when when he wrote his book uh
the external relations department of the
world bank went into overdrive and
produced sort of a you know
huge great long memo about why bruce
rich was terrible awful and couldn't be
talked to and was should be shut out of
all contact and excommunicated and
pushed off the planet
and this this memo was sort of
circulated to all people who might be
interested in
in the world bank of course therefore
just publicizing uh bruce rich's book
um sadly the world bank has learned a
lesson in its communications policy he
hasn't done that to my book
um but um in any event wilfredson then
arrived at the world bank in 1995
and invited bruce rich round to dinner
at his house
and had him sit next to him and so you
know rather than freezing out the
external critics
um was sort of working them in and kind
of you know soliciting their views
and and trying to turn enemies into
collaborators and in fact i think bruce
said that uh
one of the bank people there you know
said well now we're not enemies we're
frenemies because after such a friendly
dinner
uh we can't be enemies anymore and this
sort of so we could get a sort of case
study actually
uh in what happens when a big
multilateral organization
reaches out to ngo critics um and really
tries to bring them in and
not just by this sort of charm offensive
but in substantive ways too
creating commissions that ngos sat on to
advise the world bank
uh and trying to involve the ngos more
in its world bank projects
uh and in a variety of ways trying to
build bridges to the civil society
people
um and what did this yield is the
question uh and five years after wilson
had been there
in the 2000 spring meetings you get
anti-globalization protests which are
beating up the world bank
equally as much as they're beating up
the imf the bank gained apparently
nothing on the street at all from this
route reach
to ngos which is why i say ngos don't
always have an off switch they carry on
criticizing you no matter what you do
and it wasn't just the street protests
which were emphatic of this it was
projects bruce has mentioned one in
uganda i'll mention
another one in china where
there was going to be a movement of some
people from a place where they couldn't
really make a living agriculturally
to a new area which would be irrigated
somewhat and they could try to
grow enough food to live on and this was
attacked
because it was in tibet and it was going
to damage the tibetan people and so from
the right in congress chris cox was
attacking the world bank
and the left in congress nancy pelosi
was attacking the world bank
and important tibetans like richard gere
were attacking the world bank
and congress was against it and the
clinton treasury was going to vote
against the project
and so on and and and the project was
not actually in tibet it wasn't in tibet
it was in a neighboring province to
tibet
where one in five of the people there uh
are ethnically tibetan and which
historically you could say
used to be at one point tibet just like
texas used to be in mexico
uh but i mean that the premise the
factual premise of this
uh campaign was i think wrong and i tell
this story at some length to illustrate
the point that one shouldn't always
believe ngo campaigns and there's a
tendency where you get a press release
as a journalist
from a feisty idealistic committed ngo
to say gosh this must be all true
and then you get a press release from
the world bank which is a faceless
bureaucracy and you dismiss that
and so you go with the ngo critique and
sometimes
you can get it wrong as a result as a
journalist or as a member of parliament
and so on
so this is sort of my riff on on ngos
that it's not that they're bad
it's just that sometimes their campaigns
need to be factually
checked and if you don't check them the
result is that you block projects which
are actually rather valuable now
the interesting thing of course is that
we have this alliance in criticizing the
bank between
sort of the leftish people on the
environmental movement
and then adam meltzer who is more on the
conservative side you've got this sort
of left right
thing and and it's people like me who
are in the middle who are sort of you
know fighting off both sides
uh and uh you know this is true since
the 1980s the funny thing about the bank
is it's a public sector institution
so the right does not like public sector
institutions but it preaches
free market prescriptions and so the
left doesn't like that
and so you've got this sort of pincer
movement from left and right which is
another reason
why i'm worried that the bank long term
may be encircled
and may get weaker because if nobody
sticks up for this thing
both the left and the right will attack
it and will wind up with no good
effective world bank
we actually were engaged with the bank
an investigation of adjustment policies
took about five years so
we have some experience in this i i
think that the criticism
basically that the bank and wolfenstein
have been going around in circles is a
valid one but
be quite honest listen to this
conversation today i think this
conversation is going around in circles
um it's not very productive and i think
that's because i think all of us
sitting here in the north are talking
now at least implying that we have some
type of
approach that we would use some type of
standard to judge
development and i see a number of
fallacies and what has been said today
first i'm kind of amazed at what
sebastian just said about
ngos in the bank i mean ngos should stop
criticizing just stop going to the
street because wolfenstein's talked to
ngos
that's not the reason why people want to
deal with the bank it's not to talk to
john wilkinson is to get something done
the reason why people are still on the
street is because nothing's come out of
this dialogue
i mean it has been kind of a cover for
continuation as usual
you look at all the basic um
investigations the world commission on
dams the extractive industries review
sapri on structural adjustment nothing's
come out of these things
so why shouldn't people stay on the
street which raises a second question
which i would raise with sebastian which
is it's one thing to look at the
influence of ngos
but what about the influence of
corporations the influence of
corporations is
ten times greater than the influence of
ngos why does he waste his time on us
you know the reason why we're out there
is to try to balance in some way
the influence of the people that allen's
investigated or at least dealt with
as working with the economist for years
what about the financial sector the
influence on opening up financial
sectors overseas
what about the influence of of
corporations that are
trying to privatize economies so they
can go in and take assets in the cheap
what about traders who want to take or
producers who want to produce
cheaply in these countries i mean what
is astounding here
today and i'll throw this back to you as
well
is that you guys are saying that the
market
the last 20 years isn't just orphans in
the last 25 years
hasn't worked that the poorest people in
the world are still poor
i think that's what allen has said 700
million people
in the poorest countries are not much
better off than they were
in 1980 i believe with your quote well
that means that the whole approach that
the bank has taken
the whole market approach but all of you
in one way or another have supported
have some major questions with it where
where where are you now
on that approach and so let me just
throw this out as
a basic challenge and i want to go back
to what alan has said which i think is
very valid
the question here is accountability and
the question is not accountability to
corporations is not accountability to
governments it's not accountability to
us
the question is accountability to the
people who are going to be affected by
these
programs why not have a program an
approach
which says we are not we are going to
investigate the performance of every
program out there
but we're going to go to the people
we're going to ask them
is that this school working is this dam
actually
doing you any good is this privatization
of this utility allowing you to get
services
at affordable rates is the financial
sector review allowing you to get credit
or affordable rates and what you're
going to find is the answer those
questions is no
but i don't hear anybody out here saying
we should turn over accountability
to the people who are affected you know
i don't hear that i see it in the book
so i asked you is that something that
you would approve of that you would
that you would agree with and can we
work towards the mechanisms of
empowering people overseas not us here
in this room
but people overseas to determine what is
you know accountable programs
thank you um i agree with you completely
about accountability
but i think you that there are two
points from which i
want to disagree with you first it isn't
true that
the market system has failed the poorest
people in the world we've had enormous
progress in china
and india right not because of the bank
but because of the market system that
they've introduced the market system
they made the reforms
that's really like other countries to do
that is and the bank could help them to
do it but if
if they can do it by themselves as well
as with the bank and in many cases in
the case of china and
india they did do it largely by
themselves although india certainly we
see in
china certainly received world bank aid
it's hard to make a connection between
that aid and then the reforms so the
poorest people are
that's why poverty has dropped it's
dropped and that's part of the criticism
poverty has dropped
because of the effectiveness of opening
markets establishing the rule of law and
so on
and and not because so much because of
what the bank does second
i think you're missing the connection
between accountability
and things like the millennium challenge
account and output
based aid i mean the whole idea of
output-based aid is that we're going to
give assistance to those countries
that succeed in raising living standards
and doing things
that they promise to do and that gives a
great measure
of accountability and ownership within
the country the model that fails
is the model that the great god
wolfensohn sitting in washington
can order improvements in the lives of
people living in
goodness knows where but certainly
sub-saharan africa
allows many other poor countries i mean
that model has failed
what they can do is help countries that
want to do the things that will help
them to develop
this whole panel is an elaborate way of
taking the in your book sebastian of
taking the spotlight
off the evil corporations that really
manipulate this whole thing
i have a few sort of reactions to some
of the issues that have been raised and
i'll be really quick
first i think this debate between alan
and sebastian on who was there first on
selectivity is truly
silly i agree um good um
the fact is that alan blames um
wolfensohn for not
doing selectivity but let's look at what
the bank does
not what wolfenson seems to have said as
sebastian points out the bank does
use a system called the ida
performance based allocation which is
moving in that direction
and let us see how successful the
millennium
challenge corporation which hasn't spent
a penny yet by the way
will be with this great idea of output
based aid which we can all endorse we
can all endorse accounting
accountability to the people let's see
if it happens
it's going to turn out that it's bloody
complicated
i promise you so in two or three years
we will all be sitting here
worrying about why the millennium
challenge corporation
has repeated all the worries and all the
mistakes of
of the world bank and is not making much
progress that's my prediction i hope i'm
wrong
second i think sarat asked a really
important question
what is the objective function of the
world bank but let's keep in mind
that it is not the bank in some vague
way
that that addresses that question as
sebastian beautifully points out in his
book
it's the shareholders and for the most
part
it's the rich country shareholders it's
the us
and sometimes the u.s pushes the bank to
do things
that it might not otherwise do sometimes
the g7
as sebastian points out demands
everything from the bank
and then complains about lack of focus
if you
want to see some reforms that make sense
not radical changes but reforms that
make sense
at the world bank look to the right kind
of pressure on your own government
and keep in mind that for all the
complaining the united states
doesn't want to give up one bit of its
capital share in the bank
it's a big it's a great deal that the
rich countries have
here it's politically virtually costly
it's not costing in any politically
visible way
their taxpayers anything and in fact the
rich countries as a group are in a nice
happy
collusion with many of the middle-income
and poor countries
in which they admit that they want their
hands tied
they don't want to be pushed by
short-term political motives
to do things the way the bilateral
donors do them
that's why the world bank is is
something that we need
it's a healthy um
constraint in some ways on the the much
worse sins
of the bilateral donors and finally i
would say about
this issue of middle-income countries i
think it's ironic
that we have a plea from the right
which believes in choice and incentives
that they want to see china and brazil
and turkey
graduated when china and brazil and
turkey
want to be borrowers from the world bank
they have their reasons let's ask why
sometimes it's financial they need
counter cyclical financing when they're
in trouble and sometimes as in the case
of china
it's because they see the loans as a
very sensible vehicle
for buying good advice so
let's get back to where sebastian
started which is in the
in that awkward middle and think about
the reasonable changes and the
reasonable reforms
that could make a good institution work
even better
mr malabi what about the corporations
yeah um well i actually view mr
hedinger's
comments as sort of an example of what i
mean by when i say
uh that ngo critics don't always have an
off switch i mean
as he pointed out he was engaged with
the world bank uh in the structural
adjustment policy review initiative
for quite some time starting in 95 96
somewhere around then
um the bank you know invited advice
uh moved away not in the policy advice
terms because i think basically
structural adjustment was correct in
terms of
pressing market signals uh pressing the
idea that you shouldn't
sort of smother market signals but
structural adjustment was wrong
in the way that it was not politically
legitimate you couldn't force it down
people's throats
you needed to come to a development
consensus in a country if you wanted
those policies to stick so
that's why the bank moved more towards
sort of participatory
development where you would have a
national conference you'd bring in
churches trade unions
local ngos in the country and you would
have a
try and build a consensus in favor of
policies that would include sensible
macroeconomics but would also include
you know stuff for health stuff for
education and so on and so
there was a lot of shift uh under
wolfenstein a huge amount of shift
towards bringing ngos around the table
not only in dialogues
with mr hellinger but also in developing
countries
with the ngos locally and i tell stories
in my book about wolfenstein going out
to field offices and yelling at the
local staff because they didn't have
sufficiently good
contacts with uh with ngos in country
and forcing them to open their doors and
then there was huge numbers of outreach
officials
at the world bank whose job it is to
reach out to ngos in whichever country
you're talking about
but did anything change as a result well
yes i think they did for example in 1999
uh it was laid down that if you wanted
to get a soft loan a subsidized loan
from the world bank
you were supposed to have a development
plan created in this participatory
fashion
participating with ngos
so you know yeah there was a lot that
happened but mr hedinger is telling us
that nothing happened and therefore you
have to go and
criticize and demonstrate in the streets
i just don't agree i think this sort of
overly static view of the bank
and frankly also of poverty is the
problem poverty is on track
between 1990 and 2015 to halve
that millennium development goal is
going to be reached it's not static
that's just wrong and nor is the bank
static in 1985
the world bank had five
environmentalists a ridiculously low
number
now it's got a huge environmental
department and it's had it since
the early 90s so the bank changes in the
face of criticism but the critics don't
always change
their line that's the problem we have
time for one or two more
madame that
hello my name is kate saunders i'm from
london um
i wanted to pick up on uh sebastian's
point about the qinghai project
this is a critical chapter in the book
because china and the world bank
obviously have a very important relation
relationship um at the time in 99 i
broke the story as a journalist of this
project and reported on it for an
organization called tibet information
network
and i mentioned in the book i mentioned
as a campaigner at the time i wasn't a
campaigner
i was very concerned about the factual
inaccuracies
in that chapter and other parts of the
book which to me
cast out on the credibility of what is
otherwise a very good book
the you mentioned before about qinghai
is not part of tibet
in fact there's a very complex
historical relationship qinghai was
formed as a province by china in 1929
there were virtually no chinese until
around 1918
in the particular area that the project
was going to
was going to cover um in fact shanghai
has always been
outside the mainstream of chinese
civilization
when your researcher interviewed me i
was disappointed because
it seemed that she only wanted to choose
the facts that fitted the particular
argument
i was i was quite keen to be interviewed
her because they were by her because
there was a very interesting story
behind that
in 1954 china acknowledged the
tibetan presence in qinghai because it
divided
ching hai into five autonomous
prefectures tibetan and mongolia's
autonomous prefectures
acknowledging that tibetans and
mongolians were the indigenous
inhabitants of the area
i remember when the world bank president
of china um
referred to uh this not being a tibetan
issue
in fact china recognizes it as a tibet
issue
i explained this to the bank when i put
out the initial report about an hour
later
i had a conference call from about six
senior people in the bank
um asking me why was this issue
important to tibetans because as far as
they were concerned from sebastian's
point of view
ching hai was not a part of china one of
the arguments i i
use could you proceed to your question
please yes sir one of the arguments i
used was that the dalai lama was from
that particular area
a few months later i heard one of the
world bank people on the radio actually
saying that yes of course this is a
tibet issue because the world bank is
is the dalai lama was from that area
there are a couple of other inaccuracies
in the book there isn't
any time to go into them now but the
issue of prison labor that sebastian
mentions
as the accusation of possibly prison
labor being used as a low blow
they're made by the ngos in fact this
area was built up
by prison labor from the 1950s
i'm the author of one of the few books
in english on the chinese
lao guy system so i have a little bit of
background on that
sebastian also mentioned that the ngos
poured over policy documents to explore
where the bank had contravened its own
guidelines
in fact many senior members of bank
staff were also doing the same and
agreed with that
um including jan piercy who was the
executive director of the world bank in
the us
at the time one of the most serious
misunderstandings made in the book
though
is is about the beijing's policy on
western development which was initiated
by jansen
in 1999 and in my dialogue with the bank
at that time some very far sighted
individuals within the bank were
beginning to
get to grips with the significance of
that campaign in terms of its
far-reaching transformation of
tibetan areas and i think that the
the book does mispresent that in a way
that
senior bank staff at the time were
becoming very aware of that
just final point which is that uh the
the funding of the resettlement project
by the world bank would have set
a precedent um by an international
organization
funding beijing's strategic objectives
of demographic and economic
restructuring in the area
that point isn't conveyed clearly in the
book thank you
sebastian you whitewash the communist
policy to use slave labor and
cultural genocide my my first comment is
that
also attack of supporting insider
corporate
privileges my my first comment would be
that uh
my analogy about um critics of the bank
not always having an off switch i'm
beginning to like it more and more
um no look i mean i can't recite uh
you know 70 or 80 pages of footnotes i
have in the book
back to you but i don't think it's
inaccurate
we did correspond with you we emailed
you you sent us your explanation of the
history
of of ching hai ching hai uh was part of
it was
subject to chinese colonization way back
before this century
so i think you can argue that qinghai is
about as tibetan as texas as mexican i
think that's a fair analogy
um and and just and and if you look at
the press releases which which
came up out of congress uh and out of
various campaign groups during this
campaign it said flatly
this is a project in tibet it just
wasn't in tibet and the numbers
about how many people were going to be
moved were wrong it was just endless
factual inaccuracies in the criticisms
of the bank
so you know i i stand by what i wrote
let's have uh last one gentlemen here
um i'm sunil chako i'm a former bank
staff member
i want to ask a question uh on an area
where i believe sebastian and alan agree
uh that is on the management failures
of jim wolfensohn and alan explained
that mr wolfensohn had never managed any
large organization
before coming to the bank given about 10
years of these failures
what was the resident board of 24
sitting and doing what is their role in
terms of corporate governance
that's the first question and briefly
the second one
on the independent performance audits
that again many people have spoken about
how is that possible to be accomplished
when the immunity is so absolute
uh the bank need not give up any
documents
can spin whatever it wants um
there is no way i believe that
an independent performance audit can be
done
under those circumstances will is there
a process
to review the legislation that
uh that oh that controls
that immunity especially related to
these kinds of audits thank you
and let's combine our answer to this
with a one minute uh
wrap up um is there any points you wish
to make
who would like to be first cannot go
ahead allen quite nancy it's all it's
much more fun to go after you actually
let me just say first that
on the independent performance audit
that has partially become
the law of the united states attached to
the idea of 14 appropriation
and it's a step forward i mean we're
going to find out how many children go
to school
how many of them learn to read that's
not hard to do
uh how many of them get uh water into
the villages and so on
all right it's a first step in that
direction and it was something which
for which i give entire credit to to
jon snow who pushed that on the congress
uh second i would like to say that uh to
sebastian
just as a matter of historical record
i talked to dick armey and phil graham
both
certainly listed as right-wing
conservatives they both told me
that if we could get improvements in the
quality of the banks program
they would support additional funding
and they said that one of them said that
publicly
that was before 9 11. george bush went
to the bank and talked about increasing
the size of bank loans
before 9 11. so 911 may have had
something to do with it
but it wasn't the only reason i mean
effectiveness was an important issue
and finally i just want to say i never
demonstrated the street
nancy please i think that the
independent evaluation of not just the
bank
but of the entire donor business is
absolutely critical
this has been recommended by on the left
by the overseas development commission
the overseas development committee's
commission
five or six years ago on the right by
the meltzer commission
uh it's been recommended in what i'd
call that awkward middle
by the gorilla the walker korea group
that alan referred to at the center for
global development jeffrey sachs would
object to being
listed as a member of the right and he
was he and one other democrat signed
and agreed to those with that report
right so i'm
okay sorry alan you know it's a crude
characterization but
it's a good shortcut and at all right
left and center the point is
agree on the need for independent
evaluation
that's i think something that needs to
go forward and at the center
we have a working group that is trying
to figure out how to get
all of the donor community uh conspiring
and cooperating on some sort of the
mechanism because the problem in this
in this um area
justice sebastian says is that
unfortunately the incentives for donor
groups
and organizations like the world bank
are
to try to stay as quiet as possible
about those failures
because they open themselves up to all
of these attacks
especially from the right which
ultimately may undermine
our ability as a global community to
deal with this big challenge of global
poverty
so on that that's what i would say i
hope every person in this room
in addition to pushing the next world
bank president to read this book
will think about pushing the u.s
government to take some leadership
on this issue of independent evaluation
thanks
sebastian you get the last word well um
the bank uh
probably ought to do more on assessment
of its own performance but it does have
the operations evaluation department uh
internally has had it for uh 30 years or
something
uh maybe 25 and the head of this
operation told me a story which comes
from
june 1995 when he was parking his car in
the world bank garage and getting out
and he was almost knocked over by this
hectic and furious figure who was
sprinting towards him in the kappa
yelling at him
i've seen your report i want to shoot
myself uh
and this this crazy guy was jim wilson
who had just been appointed
president of the world bank had read a
report from the operations evaluation
department and was saying he was going
to shoot himself
because the performance of his own
institution was so appalling that he was
determined determined
to do better evaluation to kind of come
finato to change the performance to
shake it up
turn it upside down throw it out the
window catch it spin it around
do whatever it took uh to make this
thing better now
he clearly as i described in the book is
a guy with a temper and a guy with
sort of too much energy for his own good
and too many initiatives too many balls
in the air
and quite a lot of them do land on the
pavement because he doesn't catch them
but i just come back to the point that
in a way
the story of the book of the last 10
years is of a person who for all his
faults
kind of did absorb the criticism to the
bank did understand what was wrong with
the bank
and did try to push the buttons to make
it change and so you have a kind of a
case study over 10 years
in how far can we get with all these
different ideas reaching out to ngos
changing the management structure of the
bank doing more internal assessment
moving more towards output-based aid if
you're interested in any of those ideas
you do have a case study about how far
you can get with them
by looking at the last 10 years which is
what i tried to do in the book thanks
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for your participation thank you to our
panelists whatever you do this is an
excellent christmas present